people in miami beach and other
low-lying areas of florida being told to
leave and find higher ground miami beach
is on a barrier island with only a few
exit points across the bay in miami
there are big concerns over some 25
construction cranes that cannot be taken
down before irma arrives people who live
in nearby buildings are being urged to
get out mark strassman is in miami with
a plan to protect the buildings and
infrastructure mark good morning
good morning for emergency officials
here one of the many irma worries are
these construction sites and i want to
show you why take a look it's these
construction cranes that are all over
miami they're massive and heavy their
counterbalances alone can weigh up to 30
thousand pounds you do not want to be
near one of these if it starts to
collapse
when hurricane irma hits cranes like
these could start spinning like weather
veins they're designed to do that says
peter dyga he's president of associated
builders and contractors in south
florida if you were to lock them down
they would be
presenting more resistance to the wind
and cause a bigger problem the cranes
can withstand winds of up to 145 miles
per hour but irma's sustained winds have
reached as high as 185 miles per hour
and there's a fear the cranes may topple
over as this one did in new york during
superstorm sandy high-rise residents who
choose to ride out irma are also being
told to move to their building's
interior because of the cranes but also
because of flying debris
after hurricane andrew in 1992 building
codes require the use of hurricane
resistant windows they remain intact
after a single impact from a 2x4
traveling 50 feet per second
[Applause]
the problem is in a hurricane
is that
it's possible that the window gets hit
over and over and over and over again in
miami beach which on average is just
three feet above sea level storm surge
is the big worry
two years ago we visited this lab to see
how a category five hurricane sends
giant walls of water inland
miami beach has 34 pump stations ready
and another 30 on standby they won't
stop the storm surge only dry the city
out after irma leaves mayor philip
levine we won't be able to rescue people
we won't be able to help people we want
them to know that now you need to leave
miami beach
roughly 90 000 people live on the
barrier island of miami beach many of
them elderly for city leaders the hope
is to avoid traffic jams on the four
causeways that lead on and off the
island by starting that mandatory
evacuation order now
charlie
thanks mark